I think if I were to just pick two or
three interesting trends right now one I
think is the cell phone or the device
formerly known as the cell phone which
really has less and less to do with
making voice calls the latest example is
the the iphone from apple which is
really a rather powerful little computer
you can hold in your pocket the
blackberry is also a computer the trio
is also computer but the iphone sort of
takes it to a new level the evolution of
that is going to be fascinating to watch
I believe the personal computer is we
have known it has already peaked I don't
mean that it's going away it's still
going to be the dominant device but i
think it is piqued because i think
they're going to be a lot of other
devices and a lot of other methods for
doing the digital things we have thought
you needed a computer to do a personal
computer so that that whole cell phone
thing is one closely related is the
whole question of wireless networks
basically they have been the province of
huge monopolistic utility minded
companies who I like to compare to
Soviet ministries who I think have tried
to control far too much of the chain the
hardware the software everything you
want to do on a device on somebody's
cellular network has at least it in the
United States and at least up to this
point been heavily a controllable by
Verizon and AT&T and Sprint and t-mobile
and I think that's about to blow up I
don't mean that it's going to blow up
you're going to wake up one day and the
whole system is going to be blown up but
I think we are just on the verge of
seeing power flow away from those
companies and flow to either tech
companies like Google or Apple or
companies like that or consumers or some
combination of both I think Wi-Fi and
wimax and some of these other
technologies have the possibility of
blowing that open and I think you're
going to see more freedom in the
creation of software and services on
those devices so that's another big
thing I also think the less you hear the
word internet the more integrated into
our lives it will be I compared the
internet to the electrical grid the
electrical grid is all around you it's
in your home it's in your offices in
your hotel room and there's an uncounted
number of things that plug into the
electrical grid the television cameras
were using to record this interview plug
into the electrical grid so does the
toaster oven and the electric toothbrush
in the and the hair dryer that you might
have used this morning but you did not
think to yourself when you put your
toast in your toaster oven hey i'm using
the electrical grid or i'm going to use
the electrical grid you it would be
laughable for you to say that and i
think the same thing is going to happen
with the internet the internet instead
of being seen as a lot of people do as
some sort of activity you perform on a
device that happens to be called a
personal computer the internet is really
enormous grid or ocean of information
communication services commerce
marketing entertainment all of these
things information and there are going
to be innumerable devices that will
connect to it tap into it and just use
enough of it to perform whatever
function it is they are good at doing in
whatever context people want to use them
in so for instance you wouldn't
necessarily expect a pocket-sized device
to do the same thing as a device with a
larger display you wouldn't necessarily
be surprised i think in 10 years that
you're Michaels microwave oven is
plugged into the internet I think it
will be on the other hand it won't be
plugged in the internet for the purpose
of you getting your email on the door of
the microwave it'll be plugged in so
that when you put a package of frozen
food in there the oven will just read
the barcode it will have a connection to
the internet will have a database that
will be constantly updated and it'll be
able to properly heat up the food that's
the only thing it'll need the Internet
to do but it will need the Internet to
do it so Internet is a grid many devices
many kinds of software and many kinds of
services running on those devices all of
which take advantage of the grid and
that means that in 10 years already this
is true to some extent but it's going to
become Universal in 10 years whatever
you watch television you're going to be
on the internet whenever you make a
phone call you're going to be on the
internet and nobody's going to say I'm
going to go online tonight look this up
you know i think in 10 or 15 years when
you see movies from today where people
say i found this online i'm going on the
web let's go online and check it out
people going to laugh because they're
always going to be online